all right Spotify to lay off 17% of his
staff it's third round of job Cuts this
year by the way if it seems like every
couple months we're telling the story
and it's not a old story it's a new
story and this is according to wsj
Spotify set to lay another 17% of its
Workforce Pro approximately 1,500
employees making his third round of job
Cuts in 2023 as part of an effort to
boost
profitability Co Daniel Le emphasized
the need for cost reduction stating
being lean is not just an option but a
necessity company anticipates incurring
charges of up to 145 million Euros so
$157 million in the first final quarter
of the year due to the layoffs and
expect an operating loss of $93 million
to $108 million during the fourth
quarter revising down its prior forecast
of 37 million operating profit however
CFO Paul vogle remains confident in the
company's profitability projections for
2024 saying we're doing this from a
position of strength Tom are they doing
this from a position of trying to find
some money to pay Joe to renew his
contract what is this all about there
may be part of it but there there are
two things going on here one of them I'm
going to cover in a coming week on a
bisoc podcast here from value tainment
and that is the first thing is happening
is Spotify is having to right siiz its
finances for two reasons one the
underlying cost of the music is like 82%
so in other words for every dollar they
bring in they got to pay out like 82%
and it gets carved up in these little
pennies and slices of pennies and sent
out to all the the music acts and and
everything that's first it's the second
of all they're trying to make um a
podcast of success and they've had to
liberate themselves of they made some
Acquisitions that added some fat they
had uh they got rid of the Obamas they
got rid of some people that weren't
performing and they need to resign Joe
Rogan so I think they are trying to
rightsize the company for profitability
and get ready for the signing of Joe
Rogan and point B which I'm going to get
to in in a couple weeks is we're about
to see the consolidation of streaming
services the same way we saw the
consolidation of cell phone companies
that's the way it's going to work who
who's going to be the big dog behind uh
apple and Paramount plus are going to
get married um or they're going to
consolidate into a single offering and
then split proceeds but offer it as one
offering you're going to see things like
that happen the same way that you saw
look at all everything we saw in the
United States once upon a time we had
singular Bob a TNT right we had prime
Prim Co Bob by SBC and then SBC you
think Spotify will be in the buying or
the won't be in B uh Spotify is going to
be one of the buyers acquirers um I look
at Pandora is Pandora going to be there
all by itself much longer or does
Spotify kind of absorb that and be the
mega service perhaps but I think that's
the part two part one is they're trying
to rightsize their finances and get
ready for the resigning of um Joe Rogan
and they spent a hell of a lot of money
trying to get into podcasting and a lot
of it went bad other than Rogan who is
spotify's biggest content creators these
days I could they have a lot of them if
you go on they have a lot of ones yeah
they have a lot of good ones it's not
like they have one or two but nobody's
close to like Ran's contract p is ridic
they have Obama and Springsteen they had
Obama and spring they
[Music]
had by the wayside they they didn't
renew they're like we're moving on like
you guys are who are their biggest
people now other than Rogan um I I I
genuinely don't even know who is it
Robbie they've got a bunch of crime
say the names they're on Spotify like
meaning anybody you say is on Spotify
all the big names are on
Spotify whether no not exclusive people
are people are screaming it
everywhere you know they're not you know
Spotify unless if you're willing to pay
the kind of money you PID Joe to some
other podcasters most guys don't want to
have their podcast be in one place they
had to pay to get that from correct they
are a record label for Joe Rogan but
they are also the world's largest radio
station for everybody if you want to
look at it that way yeah I'm just
wondering who they paid massive out of
mon money to they spent a billion
dollars of marketing money Harry and
Megan they spent a billion dollars of
marketing money and got uh few names you
know and that's Megan and Harry they got
Kardashian they got Obama and Bruce and
they got Rogan and that was the
marketing dollars they spent when they
raise a billion they need to do that to
keep Joe yeah uh there's plenty of other
places that would love to have Joe
all those podcast Rogan's the only one
still standing all those guys basically
they're out yeah the Obamas and stuff oh
yeah for sure nobody who Who the hell's
going but as a record label they have a
lot of profitable podcasts that are at
the mid tier they're very profitable so
Obama's trying to get one of his former
employees to keep his job that's what
he's working on right now who the cook
no no no he's trying to his former one
of his former VPS he's trying to help
him to Jo bid sleepy sleepy creepy Joe
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right
here